Hi, this is Dr. Cutters.
Today we're going to continue our study in understanding the different lab tests that
one would run to help diagnose autoimmune diseases and define out what you actually have
antibodies to.
Very important when you're having an array of symptoms that you can't figure out.
Maybe you have had some testing, but it doesn't exactly point to your symptom pattern.
So, you're going to understand what I mean by that in just a couple of minutes.
Cyrex labs run different antibody tests to test for self-antibodies, aka autoimmune diseases,
and thereby give us some more information on that which I have antibodies against, thereby
giving us a lot more information on what to do clinically to help myself.
So, let's get into this and to help understand real briefly what the Cyrex array 5 is.
So again, just a quick overview, there's three different stages of an autoimmune disorder.
Stage 1 is we could do a Cyrex array 5 like this and you could have elevated antibodies,
but you don't yet have symptoms or loss of tissue function or damage to tissue.
Stage 1, we're not dealing with really anybody like that usually, though they have a lot
of symptoms.
They may have antibodies to a certain body part that they don't have symptoms with, and
you'll understand that as we look at the full array 5.
Stage 2 is elevated antibodies with symptoms, usually those are our patients because they
have symptoms.
If you don't have any symptoms, you're not looking for an doctor, right?
So, you're at least in stage 2, you have elevated antibodies on a test and you don't
know that until you get the test done, but you come to us with symptoms.
So, those are people that are going to a doctor, they have symptoms and I tell you 9 times
out of 10, the doctor's never running antibody tests, and they're never getting a proper diagnosis.
Typically, they're sent home with some psychotropic medication or something like that.
It's all in your head and it's very discouraging, you're never getting to the bottom of this.
This is a test, the Syrex array 5, and the Syrex array 7x, and some other Syrex tests are
going to get to the bottom of exactly what's going on.
It's very important to know what's going on.
It gives you a lot of peace of mind, gives you a lot of understanding, even though you might
have positive findings and that's sad, it's a lot better to know what's going on so you don't
have to deal with it than to still be in the dark with how you're supposed to fix yourself.
So, we'll get to that.
And then, stage 3 is you have elevated antibodies, you have symptoms,
and then you have measurable tissue destruction.
And a perfect example of that would be somebody with rheumatoid antibodies,
they have symptoms, they have joint pain, and they have taken x-ray,
and you can see damage to the bones or the joints themselves.
Okay, so how does an autoimmune disease happen?
Quick overview again.
You have a damage to the barrier.
Something has got into your body, into the tissues, into the bloodstream,
that your immune system fires against, and either can't kill it's a pathogen that's very difficult
to kill like Lyme disease or strep or something like that, you're not able to kill it.
That pathogen goes intracellular inside the cell, and then the immune system develops antibodies
against the cell line itself.
Example would be panzer pandas with strep and example with Lyme disease could be anything
gets inside the cell.
Your immune system develops antibodies against the cell to, you know, why would it do that?
We'll sacrifice the cell in order to save the person, or it's not a pathogen,
not a living organism, a chemical toxicity that gets inside the cell.
The immune system shouldn't fire against that chemical at all, but it does because your body's
unable to detoxify it. Some people have genetically slow detox pathways.
Some people are exposed to a lot of a, of a toxin at once that overwhelms their system,
and it gets into your body, into your cells, and it can fire an immune response,
and you can develop an autoimmune disease from that, or you can have an autoimmune disease
developed from a trauma. A lot of research on brain traumas and concussions,
causing autoimmune disease, causing microglial priming, and then also neuro antibodies,
autoimmune disease to different brain tissues, and then you can have even genetic susceptibility
to autoimmune disease, different HLA, and different gene defects that can cause, can increase
a person's risk for autoimmune disease. But you, when you were talking about pathogens
enter the body, when we were talking about toxins enter the body, we really want to look at your
barriers. You have a barrier system, you know, when we breathe things in, we're not supposed to,
you know, allow pathogens and toxins to cross the, the alveolar space in our lungs into the blood,
but they often do. Also, we were, you know, our ancestors were exposed to as many airborne toxins,
or foodborne toxins as we are. These could cross our lung border, which is really a barrier,
could cross our gut border, or barrier, because those barriers, those borders could be damaged.
And then you also have a blood brain barrier after about three years old, before three year old,
you don't even, they don't even have a blood brain barrier. That's the real danger of
of getting things in their system, drugs, and chemicals that really shouldn't be in their system,
can, can cross right into the brain, and it could cause issues. So the fastest way to get a
poison in somebody's body is to inject it. The second fastest way is to breathe it in, because our,
our lung barrier is much more susceptible to allowing things to cross. And then the next fastest
way is to, just to ingest it with having a damaged gut barrier. So if we have a really healthy gut
barrier, we're not going to even absorb many of the toxins that we're exposed to. That would be a
good thing, and those will be just deposited in the toilet. But realistically is that
when we're exposed to toxins on a regular basis, they themselves damaged the gut border.
So we end up with a damaged gut border, aka a leaky gut, and intestinal permeability. And then
things get across, that shouldn't be getting across, and we can develop food sensitivities,
and we can develop autoimmunities based upon toxins, getting across, and then like I said,
they can get into the tissues, get into the cells. Our immune system can create antibodies against
self-tissue. So again, definition of an autoimmune disease is that you have antibodies against your
own tissue. Your immune system is not supposed to make antibodies against your own tissue, but it can
be. For all sorts of reasons, that we've discussed throughout the whole autoimmune course.
But your body can make antibodies against self-tissues, and then every time you fire your immune
response, you're going to destroy that with your antibodies against first. And if you have antibodies
against your own tissue, it's going to be your own tissue. So one thing you've heard throughout
the whole course, if you're just watching this video, you're not on the course. Get on the autoimmune
and chronic disease course, because I'll say it probably a zillion times. When you fire
an immune response for whatever reason, you're going to destroy that with your antibodies against
first, and if it's self-tissue, that means it's you, you're destroyed. My antibodies against my
thyroid, and I'm going to take a whole bunch of vitamin C for whatever reason. I'm going to stimulate
my immune system, and then I will help my body destroy my thyroid. Not a good idea, right? So we
don't want to be artificially or chemically, nutritionally, stimulated in our immune system,
but sometimes it's beyond our control. Our immune system could be stimulated because we were exposed
to a pathogen cold or a virus or something. And it needs to be stimulated to kill that.
Well, you're also going to do self-destruction. That's why a lot of people with autoimmune disease
feel as good when they have even a cold. So lots of things to cover. So lots of things in that
course, but how we get an autoimmune disease is typically permeability of our barriers and exposure
to things that stimulate our immune system and exposure to things that damage our body and cause
our immune system to develop antibodies. Now, in the array five, the Syrex array five,
we're specifically testing for certain antibodies. Now, this is not all the antibodies that you could have
an auto that could create an autoimmune disease. So this is specific tissue antibodies. Now,
remember, we've talked about in other videos that there are systemic antibodies. If you have
systemic antibodies, that can actually be worse than having specific tissue antibodies. Well,
I guess I guess that's not a good way to put that, but different antibodies are, let's say in this
test, collagen antibodies. We'll go over a little more detail later. That's not a good thing to have
antibodies against because there's collagen in so many areas of our body and all our joint capsules
and things that I could have destruction and symptoms just about everywhere, right? But also
great antibodies are not good to have because when you have destruction of neural tissue, it can give you
all sorts of crazy symptoms. So none of these are good to have, right? But we want to measure them to
be able to now be able to deal with them. So this array five is a multiple autoimmune reaction
reactivity screen. It's just a screen of these different antibodies. Of course, the ones at the top,
thyroglobulin and TPO antibodies, they're your thyroid antibodies. Probably the most common autoimmune
disease that we see are as a thyroid autoimmune disease. It's typically hypo, it's called Hashimoto.
And then there's antibodies to all sorts of things that are measured and we'll go over some of these.
The test itself looks like this. Hopefully your test looks like this because this is all negative.
So if everything is in the green, like this example right here, you don't have antibodies to any of
those tissues. If things are in the yellow, that means they're slightly elevated. If things are in
the red, you definitely are out of range. So you want them to all look in the green. You don't want
antibodies to any of these. So let's say you are suspecting an autoimmune disease and we run this
test and it comes back looking like this. Well, that's good news and bad news. The good news is,
you don't have any of these antibodies. The bad news is we still don't know why you're sick. So we
got to maybe run some different tests. There's other antibody tests to run for different disorders
and we may suggest we move on to those tests. Along with each one of these antibodies,
Cyrex gives you kind of a nice little readout that you could look at it. So for instance,
we'll just look at the top one, parietal cell. Parietal cell. What are parietal cell antibodies?
So parietal just means is Latin, which means on the side. But so there's a lot of
anatomical things that are called parietal. You have parietal lobes in the brain. They're on the upper
part of the brain and that's not what this is measuring. Your parietal cells are in the stomach.
And the parietal cells do a lot of different things in the stomach. They create intrinsic factor.
They create HCl production and they secrete that. And they're associated with
being able to digest your food and send food from the stomach into the small intestine
partially digested and then enzymes from your pancreas do the rest of the work.
Having parietal cell issues, I won't say parietal cell antibodies, but having parietal cell issues
we need hypofunction of the parietal cells is probably the most common
disorder in the world. Let's say that because a hypochloridria decrease hydrochloric acid production
and secretion into the stomach is probably arguably the most common health condition
in the world. And it can lead to all sorts of things from cancer to Hpylori overgrowth to intestinal
dysbiosis, microbiota, imbalances and got issues, leaky got issues which could lead to auto
disease blah blah blah. So having good HCl production, your stomach is supposed to be the only part
of your body that needs to be extremely acidic. And if it's not acidic, you won't get that initial
stage of digestion takes place. If it's not acidic, you won't get the initial destruction of pathogens
that you eat, you eat foods that have bacteria on them, viruses, parasites. And if you have really
good HCl production, you'll kill all those things. So it's your primary source of killing pathogens
that could enter your body through food. And then that's how you digest your food and send it
into the small intestine partially digested. Now it's the work of enzymes from that point on. But if
you have antibodies to the parietal cells, you're going to have all sorts of problems from issues with
creating intrinsic factor. That's the second one, but we're not talking about antibodies to
intrinsic factor here. Antibodies to parietal cells, you're going to have issues with stomach
issues, you know, just galore, which could lead to all sorts of symptoms. So each one of these
things could create a whole array of symptoms by themselves. So we want to test for it. So it's
not enough to know why a person has fatigue or not enough to know that a person has fatigue
to get a diagnosis. We need to know why. So it could be parietal cell antibodies. It could be
intrinsic factor antibodies. So they're not making a intrinsic factor. The second one of this list
and they're not absorbing B12. So they have a B12 ademia. It could be thyroid antibodies. That's the
blue ones here. Thyroglomial and thyroid peroxidase antibodies. So they actually have Hashimoto's.
So they have a decrease T3 in their blood, which is low thyroid. And they're getting all sorts of
symptoms for T. It's just one of them. So we want to test these. And this Syrex array five tests all
of these. And these are this list. And that can tell us why a person is having symptoms. And then
gives us information on what to do about that. And how to deal with possible triggers that are
creating a worsening of that in a greater destruction of the tissues that you have antibodies against.
So this would be an example of an array five that is not good. Okay, this is this is a pretty bad
case here. They have equivocal antibodies. That's in the yellow for primal cell. That means it's
elevated. It's not completely out of normal. But it's elevated in that equivocal range.
Not a good situation. And the ones that are in red are out of range. And there could be a lot of
damage to those tissues. So let's just look at the one in red here. The first one here. Biocardial
peptides. Biocardial peptides. Where have I heard that word before?
Biocardial. That's your heart. Well, when I go over these tests with people, I like to do them
on a Zoom call, because then I'm going to pull up these clinical spec sheets. So there's a
clinical spec sheet that that Syrex has put together on each one of these because the average layperson
doesn't know what any of these things made. The average doctor doesn't know what any of these things
made. So go through the clinical spec sheet. We would pull up Biocardial peptides. And I'd show
this on the screen. What is a Biocardial peptides? Well, peptides. Those are enzymes. Those are actually
proteins, pieces of proteins that make up your heart tissues. Biocardial, your heart, peptides,
pieces of protein that make up your heart tissue. So Biocardial peptides says right here in
clinical significance are higher levels prior to onset of dilated cardiomyopathy. So we can read
that. We can help understand that a little bit. If I have, if these are in the red on my Syrex 5,
every time I stimulate my immune system for whatever reason, I'm going to have more destruction of
these and I have the chance of having more destruction of my heart tissue. So this is not going to
affect specifically the endothelium of the vessel. So your heart is made up of muscle tissue,
right? And then you have vessels that feed that tissue. So when you think of a heart attack,
it's a blockage of those vessels. They're by starving the myocardium, the muscle of oxygen and
that myocardium area can die and that's what could, that's what a heart attack is. So myocardial peptides
are actually damaging the myocardial tissue. That's the muscle of the heart. And so symptoms of this
could be like fatigue because I have weakening of my muscles of my heart. So most common symptom would
be fatigue. More and more destruction, you're going to have literal heart disease, loss of tissue,
and not, not good. Now that shows in this box up on top, it says function and then to the right,
it says antibodies appear in these type of diseases. And then there's list of references where these
antibodies appear in these types of diseases. But it doesn't mean we're not diagnosing a disease here,
but it says, okay, you have antibodies to myocardial peptides. The symptoms you're going to have are
anything that's going to cause that you'd have with a weakened heart. So tells us what we need to
do everything we can to to comb our immune system because what our immune system is flared,
destruction of this tissue is going to take place. The other thing that this spec sheet gives us is
what you'll see in the center there. It says known cross reactions. And it gives us a link to
paper that was published about the possible cross reaction to myocardial peptides in this case. And
it says gliadin there. Well, what's gliadin? Well, if you followed anything on our autoimmune course,
gliadin is the protein that's in gluten. So gluten, what's gluten, gluten is in wheat,
rice, belt, malt, and it is it is the protein in there. Everybody's heard of gluten these days,
right? So a known cross reaction is gliadin. So this right here gives us extreme clinical significance
for a person with myocardial peptides. We don't have to run any other labs.
Now we want to I'm going to show you why we want to run other labs. But we don't have to run any other
labs to know that this person shouldn't eat gluten. Why? Because gluten is a known cross reaction
for myocardial peptides. Let's say we even did a sinerex array three, four, and ten. And they
didn't have antibodies to gluten. It doesn't make any difference. We're not talking about this
person have anti, but having antibodies to gluten. We're talking about this person every time they eat
gluten. It's going to fire a reaction to myocardial peptides has that capability because it's across
reactive substance to myocardial peptides. And when you eat gluten, you can actually be causing
destruction of your heart. So gluten is off the table. It doesn't make any difference if it causes
you tummy aches. It doesn't make any difference. I'm doing a test for gluten and it was negative.
I don't care. That makes no difference. It is a cross reactant to this. So known cross reactants
to that which you have antibodies against in this case myocardial peptides immediately takes
that thing off the table if it's a food. Follow me. So this person you have myocardial peptides,
you can't include it. Sorry. Here's another one intrinsic factor. See this one doesn't have
any known cross reactants. So therefore we wouldn't change the person's diet per se total
and based upon this intrinsic factor being positive. Now again there's a reason to run a CyRx 10
which looks at antibodies to foods because if you have antibodies to let's I'm just say let's say
uh cashews pretend okay if I have antibodies to cashews every time I eat cashews I get a fire
in immune response. And remember every time you fire in immune response for whatever reason you're
going to destroy that which you have antibodies first and if I had antibodies to intrinsic factor
and I'm eating cashews I'm going to be stimulating my immune system and guess what I'm going to
destroy by intrinsic cells so we can't do that. So this is why a person you know again what is
intrinsic factor intrinsic factor is released by the parietal cells it's a glycoprotein
that is absolutely 100% necessary for you to absorb B12 so you will not absorb B12 if you don't
have a intrinsic factor. Now the number one reason why a person has low intrinsic factor isn't because
they have antibodies um to intrinsic factor the number one reason why a person doesn't have enough
intrinsic factor it is not absorbing B12 it has got B12 deficiency uh which is called B12
edemia is because they have issues with the parietal cells because of either antibodies to the
parietal cells or damage to the parietal cells and they're not producing HCl if you're not producing HCl
you're not going to produce intrinsic factor you're going to have a B12 edemia. So remember I said
the number one issue would probably help issue in the world is damaged parietal cells and that's
typically due to poor diet chemicals in the diet things that can damage the gut at the stomach
so eat things that are not good for us a bunch of chemicals they damage our parietal cells in the
stomach are initial ability to make HCl and make intrinsic factor we end up with B12 edemia we end up
with hypochloridria decrease hydrochloric acid and we end up with all sorts of problems I know I'm
talking really fast you might have to watch this a couple times but I want to get through this and
for people who have listened to a lot of my videos. Here's another example I just pulled up another
example of collagen this is another spec sheet let's say I had antibodies to collagen complex
not a good one to have because there's collagen in so many tissues it's a part of our connective
tissue system it's a part of our ligaments and our tendons and our joint capsules so if I have
antibodies to collagen I could have symptoms of arthritis I could have an x-ray that shows damage
joint joint destruction and it's like oh you have arthritis and it's because of your injury when
you played football in high school well it could be that it could be just a wear and terror
arthritis but it could be that I have antibodies to collagen complex now you look at the cross
reactions to these some of these cross reactions you can't really do anything about claustridia
claustridia botulinum okay well I can't completely prevent things that I'm going to be exposed to
strap that I might be exposed to club cellar that's walking pneumonia I could be exposed to those
things what what am I supposed to do well some things you can't do anything about but look at these
other ones chicken collagen cow pig goat dog collagen cow collagen cow gelatin you certainly don't
want to be taking a collagen supplement okay so there's a clinical gem there I can't figure out why
I would I take call it my wife takes collagen and her hair looks really nice and it's
how she tried to get me to take collagen I don't know I just felt worse baby this is why right so
certainly if you did have collagen complex antibodies you would feel worse because when you're taking
collagen it's across reacted to collagen antibodies it's going to fire that immune response in your
body and it's going to destroy more collagen tissue so you and even in the food itself okay well
you have to be careful eating too much I wouldn't say you don't eat meat but I wouldn't eat the
gristle of my chicken leg you know you just got to be careful with some of those things so
using the this knowledge can help you decrease triggers and immune triggers to help decrease
symptom flares so very important information to know so remember permeability of the barriers can
increase risk of autoimmune issues this is how we got to this point and loss of immune tolerance
that we've talked about in different things we're exposed to pollutants toxins hormonal changes immune
reactive dietary proteins infections stress responses so this kind of gives us an idea of some
other testing we're going to do okay well we have you know antibodies to self tissue we have antibodies
to collagen or antibodies to myocardial proteins now what do I do about it does that tell me how I got
this no it doesn't tell me how I got to this point but it tells me that I'm at this point and I need
to do something about it now so once I'm at this point now I can run other tests to figure out
was it pollutants am I exposed to different pollutants that I need to clean out of my diet that I need to
help detox um out of my diet is there is there pathogens that I was exposed to that I currently have
do I currently have an active antigen in Lyme disease or strap or something that I have to maybe use
an antibiotic to kill do do I have you know hormonal imbalances that I need to work on do I have you
know there's all sorts of things that we need to uncover so we do need to do some other tests now if
we have elevated Syrix 5 we need to run some other tests if we don't have any elevations in Syrix 5
if you still have symptoms to figure out what is causing them but running toxicity tests pathogen
tests um be other immune food reactive tests are really important because like I used in that example
of the cashew if I'm eating a food that's causing a stimulation of my immune system every time I eat
that food even though it might have caused me any tummy ache uh I'm gonna fire an immune response
and I'm gonna destroy that which I have antibodies against any time you stimulate your immune system
if you have self antibodies you're gonna destroy that self tissue a little bit more um then there's
tests to run to run measure border tests and other antibody tests if like Syrix 7 um to measure
neural antibodies so there's other things to look at but this gives you a nice idea of what could
be going on that's causing my symptoms um and I didn't go over every one of those things and literally
I could have a video on each one of those tissues that is that is tested in each one of these arrays
that can give us all sorts of different symptoms but time constricts that so this gives you a good
overview and then we'll go over in your test exactly what's going on and um give you some ideas
I want to do all right hope you're blessed by this thank you much bye bye